Welcome back to the Seat Pleasant 2:35 PM Draft.
Shirts have the first pick, but the question is will they go with Kevin Durant...
...a four-time NBA all-star; he's back in town to play,...
...or with local spark plug Anton Barrels; he's a regular here.
He can't ball; he's just tall.
Have you seen my highlights?
Durant's got guard-like skills in a big man's body.
He's got a wingspan that goes on for days.
But Anton Barrels has scouts intrigued.
This guy is like a bowling ball; he's got a low center of gravity...
...so you can't get up underneath him, and he never backs down.
Well the moment has come, let's go to the podium.
And with the first pick in the 2:35 Seat Pleasant Draft, the Shirts select...
...Kevin Durant.
What?